So yesterday was Memorial Day here in the
United States.
Donald Trump was at a wreath laying ceremony
and I got a ton of emails and a bunch of articles
I read arguing that Donald Trump was visibly
struggling to stand at a Memorial Day event
and that there is this sort of weird way in
which Trump seems to be off balance and regularly
recalibrating his balance.
So I'm not going to spend a ton of time on
this.
If you know my show, you know, we've covered
Trump's strange behavior, whose sources we've
never yet determined.
We've not yet determined.
And I'm going to talk about that a little
bit.
Let's let's first look at the videos and then
I'll tell you what I think.
Here is one video during a rendition yesterday
of the national anthem.
And Donald Trump does seem unable to just
stand up straight.
His whole upper torso is sort of rocking for
forward and back as he's in a salute position.
And it wasn't a windy day.
Reports are that wind was only four miles
per hour.
No one else is swaying in that way.
And that was the source of some of the concern.
Here is another video from yesterday in which
Donald Trump walks up to a wreath and is staring
at it.
And again, he's kind of swaying in the wind,
sort of swaying back and forth.
And he does at moments seem like he's going
in the direction of falling over.
But his balance system realizes it and compensates
by pulling him back.
So I want to be like a hundred and ten percent
crystal clear.
This could be something or it could be nothing.
And we've seen we've seen this type of stuff
since day one with Trump.
These inner ear balance type issues can be
related to all sorts of different things in
earlier stages, sometimes even before other
dementia symptoms develop, starting to have
issues.
Balancing when standing or walking can suggest
an increased potential to develop Alzheimer's
or other types of dementia.
Balance issues can be related to medications
side effects.
People speculate that Trump takes stimulants.
Stimulants can certainly affect your balance,
but they can also simply affect your ability
to sit still because you're energized in this
way that uppers, stimulants and amphetamines
can can do.
This could also be Trump's weird stance.
I know some of you are aware that Trump stands
in a very weird way, kind of hinged forward
at the at the hips that might make it difficult
to stand still.
There's speculation that Trump stands that
way because he wears lifts in his shoes, which
sort of lean him forward.
What we know is this is not new.
What we know is it wasn't windy yesterday.
Trump wasn't getting blown around by wind.
So if you say to me, do I think something
is up here, big picture.
You all know I think something's up.
And I don't know if the video from yesterday
is part of it or if it's something new or
if it's nothing.
If you say, do I really care?
Well, I care if it's something that's impacting
Trump's cognition because he's the president
of the United States.
Whether or not something like this explains
Trump's behaviors and actions, Trump has failed.
Either way.
Right.
Like the Corona virus response has been a
failed response.
Whether Trump has dementia, an inner ear issue
is abusing drugs or whatever the case may
be.
It could be ADHD.
Right.
I mean, maybe Trump can stand still, but does
a good job because he has ADHD and it's hard
for him to stand still.
Who cares?
Right.
The point is he's not doing a good job.
And he can't stand still and looks unstable
and looks confused and got off of Air Force
One and didn't recognize his own limo in front
of him and wandered off until a Secret Service
agent brought him back holding him.
Is that why he's a bad president?
No.
He'd be a terrible president no matter what
the explanation is.
Does it aggravate the lethality of this presidency?
Yeah.
It probably does.
Will we ever know what's really going on here?
I don't know.
I know inside the Reagan White House, they
knew while he was president that he was starting
to show signs and symptoms of Alzheimer's.
It was learned sort of officially, publicly
later.
Only in retrospect did people start figuring
out that it was not something that happened
only after he was out of office.
He was experiencing symptoms while he was
in office.
My instinct is we probably would not get anything
definitive about Trump while he is in office.
It is yet another reason to get him out in
November, meaning he would leave in January
rather than giving him another four years.
Hopefully someday we do know exactly what
it
is
that is going on.